these two have a long complicated
history and every time they meets it's
always a coin toss to see how they're
going to react well they fight while
they work together keep watching to
learn more about the bizarre
relationship between spider-man and
venom in 2007 Spiderman read Peter
Parker's bonding with the Venom symbiote
does more than change the color of his
costume and enhances powers it makes him
a jerk the symbiote boosts destructive
emotions in Peter like anger and
jealousy what are you gonna give a guy
in parade you want forgiveness get
religious among other things he hunts in
attempts to kill Sandman and brings Gwen
Stacy to a nightclub in a manipulative
plan to make Mary Jane jealous he even
gets in a fight with the club's bouncers
which ends with him accidentally hurting
Mary Jane it's this last act that makes
Parker realize what's happening and
finally take action to get rid of the
symbiote in the comics however things
work out a little differently well the
symbiote made spider-man do things
against his will it didn't do so by
turning him into an evil version of
Peter Parker rather than finding the
costume on earth like he did in the film
Peter picked it up out in space during
the events of secret Wars and shortly
after he returned to New York with his
new suit the symbiote apparently decided
that its host was a little too lazy most
nights the symbiote waited until Parker
was asleep took over his body and went
out to find more crime to fight all the
while controlling its human hosts
unconscious body like a puppet one of
the first Clues Parker has that
something is wrong is when he constantly
wakes up exhausted
even though as far as he knows he's been
asleep in bed for hours while the
symbiote doesn't turn Peter Parker into
a jerk in the comics it's clear it
impacts his mental states and other more
subtle ways how do we know because it
takes Peter who's as much a scientist as
Bruce Banner and Tony Stark
a pretty long time to start examining a
strange unknown symbiotic life-form that
he picked up on an alien planet despite
the fact that it produces its own
webbing and can shape-shift it look like
anything from a costume to regular human
clothing he doesn't get around to
figuring out what it actually is until
things start to go very very badly after
picking up the alien costume at Secret
Wars number 8 Peter returns to earth an
amazing spider-man number
2:52 it's not until six months later
that he finally approaches the Marvel
Universe's resident super scientific
genius the Fantastic Four's Reed
Richards to help him figure out just
what's going on with his new costume for
months spider-man simply accepts the
fact that he's wearing a freaky magical
alien suit he doesn't know anything
about clearly that costumes messing with
its head it's easy to argue that during
Secret Wars where all of Marvel's most
prominent heroes and villains were
brought to another planet and forced to
battle each other Spidey was desperate
enough to just accept whatever he could
find to boost his chances of survival
once it returns to earth though maybe
putting that thing under the microscope
should have been his first priority in
1985 s web of spider-man number one the
symbiote betrays the emotional
connection developing between it and
Peter Parker by revealing a quality that
you might not expect from a murderous
alien life-form compassion while peter
is slipping on his classic red and blue
Spidey suits in his apartment
the symbiote returns from being
imprisoned in the Fantastic Four's
headquarters and attempts to bond with
him once again Peter tries to return to
the Baxter building to get help from the
FF but the symbiote does everything it
can to keep him away from the building
eventually Peter gets enough control to
make his way to a Cathedral taking
advantage of the symbiotes weakness to
loud noises by using the ringing of the
church bells as a weapon in the process
Peter gets knocked out and while it
initially slithers away to escape the
bells the symbiote returns to save Peter
from the thunderous sound the narration
tells us that its bond with Parker
caused it to experience emotion for the
first time before disappearing we see
the alien reach out caressing Peters
cheek in spite of the Venom symbiote
bonding with more than a dozen other
characters since leaving Peter Parker
there are two behaviors that show us how
fixated it is on spider-man first
there's its tendency to bond with people
that are already in Peters social
circles Eddie Brock is the first and
most obvious example since he was a
rival photographer at the Daily Bugle
the first time he merged with venom
photography it's not just about no
offense flagpoles whatever it's about
lighting composition drama other hosts
include Mac Gargan better known as the
Spidey villain the scorpion but he's not
the only established
guide to hook up with the symbiotes in
the pages of superior spider-man the
comic where Peters identity was taken
over by Doctor Octopus it temporarily
bonded with doc Ock's brain and Spidey's
body after Brock the man to have stayed
with the symbiote for the longest amount
of time was Peter Parker's former bully
and best friend Flash Thompson who used
it to perform covert missions for the
government under the code name agent
venom what's equally telling is how
venom manifests visually the symbiote
has the ability to mimic any set of
clothing but no matter who the host is
or where they fall on the moral spectrum
venom continues to base its appearance
on spider-man's the eyes of its mask and
the spider emblem on its chest are
clearly mirrors of Spidey's costume as
is the fact that it continues to sling
webs around something other symbiotes
just don't do spider-man and venom don't
exactly have the best relationship but
occasionally there's something bad
enough to force them to work together
and it usually comes from venom himself
more often than not SIF Parker and Brock
are on the same team it's because one of
Venom's own spawn is up to no good
like the insane and powerful villain
Cletus Kasady better known as carnage
when I get out of here and I will
there's gonna be Cara Nature
venneman Spidey famously teamed up
against the villainous symbiotes along
with other Marvel heroes in the 1993
event maximum carnage a hugely popular
storyline that inspired the classic
16-bit video game of the same name there
is a good reason why they had to team up
to physically carnage is more powerful
than spider-man and venom combined and
even more durable among other things the
villain has survived being beheaded as
well as being dragged into space and
ripped in half
even worse Cassidy was already a
convicted serial killer before he got
superpowers when his cellmate Eddie
Brock escaped from prison a scrap of the
symbiote was left behind then a
terrifying new villain was born in that
respect carnage can be thought of as
Venom's son but the symbiotes clearly
don't have the same warm fuzzy feelings
the rest of us have towards family still
the fact that venom chose to stay on
Team Spidey when he had to choose
between siding with Peter Parker or
teaming up with his own spawn says a
whole lot about his complicated
relationship with spider-man it's clear
the Venom symbiote has complicated
feelings towards Peter Parker but it's
also clear that those complex feelings
are a two-way street
Venom's place in the Marvel Universe is
always cycling between antihero and
full-on villain he can spend time as a
less forgiving crime fighter as he did
in a series of solo titles that started
in 1993 with venom lethal protector but
cut to 10 years later in 2003 venom and
he's right back to eating people for fun
and yet in spite of Venom's
unpredictability and his shifting
loyalties
spider-man never gets proactive about
shutting him down even though he's the
one with the great responsibility of
bringing the symbiote to earth in the
first place instead he's far more likely
to form an uneasy alliance with him like
he did to battle carnage and seems to
hold out hope that the symbiote could be
redeemed that might be a result of his
bond with the symbiote leaving him with
an emotional connection but there's
plenty of evidence that Spidey might be
right after all during its time is agent
venom the symbiote spent a long time
bonded to one of Parker's closest pals
Flash Thompson who in addition to being
Peter Parker's best friend was once
literally the president of the
spider-man fan club
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighbor it has a
dope suit and I really respect him
Thompson's venom was a much more
traditionally heroic version of the
character and even served alongside the
guardians of the galaxy and a covert
squad of Avengers while he was out in
space
the symbiote revealed a previously
unknown tragic past starting out as a
relatively peaceful member of an alien
species called the Clint R before being
driven mad after mistakenly bonding with
a genocidal maniac
Thompson's innate sense of honor however
showed the symbiotes a better way to
live and use its great power a little
more responsibly whether that will stick
remains to be seen but for now venom
seems to be pretty firmly on the side of
the good guys more or less Miles Morales
is probably best known these days as the
star of 2018 s animated hit spider-man
into the spider verse in the comics like
in the film miles was originally from an
alternate universe to Peter Parker but
was transported to the prime Marvel
Comics universe by a cosmic event that
restructured the multiverse as a result
when Miles runs into Eddie Brock in 2018
s venom number three it's their first
meeting and their introduction doesn't
go well with his symbiote being
controlled by the dark God null venom
comes close to killing Miles the younger
spider-man manages to temporarily
incapacitate the symbiote which gives
Brock a chance to take over Eddie thanks
miles and tries to explain what happened
but miles doesn't give him the chance
Miles understandably presses the attack
against Eddie and venom is forced to
fight back while Miles has never met
Eddie Brock before that issue he isn't a
stranger to symbiotes back in his home
universe his life was thrown into
disarray by that world's version of
venom in 2013 during a story
appropriately titled venom war venom
nearly killed Miles his father and his
mother died as a result of the conflict
with that kind of history it's easy to
see why Miles wouldn't be inclined to
give Eddie the benefit of the doubt once
he was attacked
eventually in true Marvel team-up
fashion the fight led to miles and Eddie
working together for the next few issues
time will tell what happens next time
these two fan favorites cross paths
Marvel has been putting out issues of
what if on and off since 1977 giving
readers the chance to experience what
stories would be like if they worked out
differently usually if the answer is
that things would be pretty bad but
1989's what if number four takes things
to the next level the question this time
around is what if the alien had
possessed spider-man and things wind up
a whole lot worse for everyone including
both Peter Parker and the symbiote the
Venom symbiote of what if number four
never develops the same emotional
attachment to Peter Parker as the main
continuities venom does instead it feeds
on its host like a vampire
draining peter's youth and vitality in
the process once Parker's lifeforce is
spent
the symbiote starts looking for a bigger
meal and chooses the Hulk as his next
host it interrupts the massive battle
between the Hulk and the Avengers that
readers had originally seen in
Incredible Hulk number 300 and bonds
with the green Goliath as he does Peter
Parker's body is revealed to have been
prematurely aged leaving him as a
withered husk Peter dies not long after
and the Avengers pursue the venom
infected Hulk until the symbiote trades
up once again leaving the Hulk's body
for Thor's the heroes finally
incapacitate venom by getting help from
the inhuman leader Black Bolt whose
deafening scream forces the symbiote
from Thor's body and destroys Mount
Rushmore in the process before the
assembled heroes can banish the symbiote
to another dimension the black cat kills
it in revenge for Parker's death all
things considered it's a much less happy
ending than we got in the regular comics
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU we're coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]